are you ready to learn a bunch of facts
about demon slayer that you probably
didn't know of course you are let's get
started demon slayer's creator kiyoharu
gotoge remains anonymous to the public
gotogh's biological gender also remains
unknown but it's believed that the
creator of the demon slayer is a female
the hashida are the most powerful
members of the demon slayer core and
there are only nine of them to become
one a demon slayer needs to kill at
least 50 demons or one of the demon
moons that belong to the 12 kazuki
rengoku's favorite food is sweet
potatoes giome is the only known demon
slayer that doesn't use an actual blade
he's also blind due to a fever he had as
a child muzan kibutsuji is around 1 000
years old the demon slayer mark appears
on demon slayers after experiencing
life-threatening conditions tanjido's
awakened after he was attacked by a
demon called gyutero the marks look like
tattoos or scars and grant the bear
extra abilities to help them in battle
people who awaken the demon's layer mark
usually die by the age of 25. tengen and
inosuke are the only demon slayers that
use two nichiren blades instead of one
muichiro tokito is the youngest hashira
in the demon slayer core being only 14
years old gyomehimejima is the oldest
hashira even though he's only 27 years
old all other hashida's ages range from
18 to 23 demon slayer mugen train movie
is the highest grossing anime movie of
all time making just over 500 million
dollars it became the highest grossing
japanese movie of all time and even
became the first non-hollywood movie
topping the annual box office
gyomehimejima is the tallest character
in the demon slayer universe being 2.20
meters tall frengoku became hashida by
killing lower moon rank 2 demon at the
time ringoku's ninth form dragon was
anime original and did not appear in the
manga the only confirmed human to
survive above the age of 25 while having
a demon slayer mark was yorichi he was
also the first breathing style user the
literal translation of the name tanjiro
is high-valued second sun while kamado
translates to the stove mitsuri's hair
is said to be pink because of her eating
too much sakura mochi the anime makes it
clear that tanjuro has a keen sense of
smell however one tiny detail most fans
didn't notice is that tangido is able to
smell underground as shown when he was
tracking swamp demon tanjido is his own
barber we could see early in the show
that he gives himself a haircut the
movie's title was supposed to be
infinite train instead of mujintrain
however it was changed to avoid issues
with the cartoon named infinity train
that was shown on the cartoon network
the voice actor of nezuko akarikito has
the exact same height as nezuko five
feet the average budget for a single
episode of demon slayer is around eighty
thousand dollars the hashidas are the
best of the best when it comes to demon
slaying which is why they not only
possess their very own unique breathing
styles but their own territories to
protect every single hashida is given
authority over a specific region or area
in which they not only have to protect
people from demon attacks but also
gather intel on the demons residing
there nezuko tamayo and yushiro are the
only demons in the entire show not under
the influence of muzan muzan has seven
hearts and five brains meaning
decapitating him would not kill him he
also has the ability to absorb people's
cellular memories muzan baby form is
equal to the three-floor building
rengoku's voice actor hatoshikino is an
excellent swordsman in real life as well
like any other organization in the world
the demon slayer corps has a strict
hierarchy the newest demon slayer is
always allotted the mizunoto rank by
default which is the lowest rank from
that they have to train hard practice
their breathing styles and kill demons
in order to progress to various other
upper ranks the highest rank allotted to
anyone in the organization is called the
kino tanjido has very rough hands this
is a small detail that's mentioned only
for a few seconds in the anime something
many fans probably missed ever since
tanjido decided to become a demon slayer
he had to find a master and undergo
strict training it's been noted that his
master sakonji urokodaki's tough
training resulted in tanjido's hands
becoming rougher the breath of sun is
the first breathing style ever created
and all other breathing styles are
derived from it as the result of yorichi
the creator of sun breathing modifying
it to suit the individuals he taught
tanjido was banned from a specific
hashida training activity this occurs
during the hashida training arc when the
demon slayer manga the hashida training
program as the name suggests is the
program for demon slayers to participate
in tanjido manages to finish every
course he participates in except one and
that is the win hashida's course who
have banned him for attacking one of
their own genya tanjido's face scar
completely changes during the final
selection how many of you noticed that
although it's not stated explicitly the
manga implies heavily that muzan and
kagaya are related to each other kagaya
says that his bloodline was cursed
because of a demon that came from it
this demon was the original demon which
would mean the first of its kind fans
know that muzen is the first demon ever
so it makes sense that muzan comes from
the obuyashiki's bloodline akaza is the
only upper moon that people got to see
in the anime so far he is one of the
most interesting demons and the only one
that fights completely bare-handed fire
plays an important part in the commodore
family they respected fire and we see
their father during a flashback perform
a traditional dance in a ring of torches
on new year's day this may go some way
in explaining why both the siblings have
firebase powers with nizuko able to
manipulate demonic flames from her blood
that don't hurt humans tanjido wears a
pair of hanafuda earrings that he
inherited from his father when muzan
kabutsuji the serious villain sees
tanjido's earrings he sends two of his
subordinates after the young demon
slayer muzan had a near-death encounter
with a demon slayer who wore those same
earrings and that's why he's so scared
of tanjiro and wants him dead before
tengen uzui became a demon slayer and
then
he was originally a shinobi muichiro
tokito is a descendant of kokushibo he
possesses the strongest bloodline and
has the ability to surpass every hashida
in the current generation once
urokodaki's students complete their
training he carves them a fox theme
warding mask to wear during their final
selection each mask has a different
design that is unique to the wear
sabito's mask had a pale scar in the
same spot as the scar on his cheek while
makomo's mask had flowers that reflected
the flowers on her kimono tanjiro's mask
has a red sun-shaped symbol over his
scar the color and shape of this symbol
resemble the design on tanjiro's
hanafuda earrings too in japan the name
of the show is kimetsu no yaiba which
literally translates to demon killing
blade demon slayer manga already ended
and it sold over 150 million copies
worldwide muzan kobutsuji creates demons
using his blood if a demon happens to
show potential muzan will share more of
his blood with that demon blessing it
with even more power the 12 strongest of
these demons make up the 12 kazuki
however if a kazuki reaches its limit
they become useless to muzan and have
their title and number stripped the
demon kyogai is a prime example kagaya
is the 97th leader of the demon slayer
corps he was only four years old when he
was granted the title muzan can't
tolerate being called pale or dead after
his initial encounter with tanjido muzan
bumps into three drunk humans then one
of the drunks comments on muzan's pale
skin and how he looks ready to fall over
dead suddenly muzan's demeanor changes
his eyes flash in irritation and anger
and he kills the group without remorse
or hesitation his strong reaction is a
result of his fear of death he devotes
his life to making himself immortal and
cannot stand the thought of dying or
being limited in any way yorichi is
easily the most powerful demon slayer to
ever live he comes the closest to
killing muzan single-handedly making the
demon hide from him for the rest of his
life despite the fact that the hashida
did exist at that point in time and that
yorici fought alongside them he is never
confirmed to have been one himself if he
was he wasn't one for long as the
hashida rejected him after his brother
became a demon and he failed to kill
muzan muzen is obsessed with finding the
blue spider lily as it's an essential
item that would allow him to walk in the
sunlight despite creating a large number
of demons and having his best
subordinates constantly on the lookout
for the plant no one was ever able to
locate it the reason for this is that
the blue spider lily only blooms at day
time two or three days a year and then
it closes back up resembling that of a
big horsetail weed click on this video
where we cover all things you missed in
attack on titan